welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and we just got a new trailer for
marvel's miss marvel a new series coming
to disney plus it looks like on june 8th
which is interesting i'll talk about
that in a bit i literally just rolled
out of bed realizing this trailer
dropped was not expecting it that's why
my eyes may still look a little puffy
this is what they do in the morning i'm
like a baby puppy before the hours of 11
a.m
why is everything so bright anyway i
have been super excited for the series
ever since they announced it i'm gonna
react to this trailer give some first
thoughts and then tomorrow as always
will be my frame by frame breakdown of
everything that you missed in this
trailer all right let's take a look here
we
go
oh cool
well that's fun already this looks
different
i just want to say
i get it i love what they're doing this
is really cool high school
kamala kamala another adventure shirt
cute do you think this is kind of weirdo
you were a word i know always excuse me
yeah
you're kind of on my shirt sorry
what you're staring at the window in
your little fantasy land
come on hey all ready really come on
like do i have to figure out my whole
future before launchers
iman vilani is really great this is
great casting too much time
and fantasyland
that is not you
it's not really the brown girls from
jersey city
you saved the world
interesting
whoa
did something happen this is a cool
choice
what does it feel like
cosmic
cosmic
i just thought i wanted this kind of
life
but i never imagined any of this
do you know what you are
i'm a superhero
good song choice i mean you gotta love
going with the weeknd it's just like
such a jammer
i mean my eyes are still waking up
okay so already this show miss marvel is
looking completely different from any
mcu thing that we've seen before yes it
is going after a younger audience and if
you watch pixar's turning red there's a
lot of similar vibes here just exploring
the mind of a teenage girl the
imaginative places it goes the goofy
stuff that she doodles and how she views
everything in her world through the way
that she would doodle it in her diary
and i love it not only is it just like
an aesthetic layer on top of a superhero
story this informs the entire way kamala
khan's superhero-ness manifests so a bit
of background on kamala khan and yes i
like how in the trailer they have to uh
correct kamala khan versus kamala khan
it's a bit of a reversal because when we
first heard of a kamala harris a lot of
people mispronounced it as kamala harris
and she had to correct us but here
kamala has to fix it back so it's kamala
khan kamala khan is a pakistani american
teenager who lives in jersey city who's
always idolized the avengers especially
captain marvel she was actually
introduced in captain marvel comics
around 2013 and was such a popular
character a character whom we had never
really seen in marvel comics before
showcased in any way in 2014 she got her
own spin-off series that was very
popular now in the comics her powers
come about in a very interesting way
they actually go a similar way as uh the
inhumans cree technology she gets
enveloped in one of these creek cocoons
filled with terrigen mist actually
there's like a terrigen mist outbreak
that spreads throughout the city and she
goes into a sort of hallucinogenic fever
dream in which captain marvel and uh and
captain america other avengers speak to
her and she's left with a power set that
is similar to captain marvel but really
she's known for the ability to uh
stretch out her body limbs and biggen
her fists and punch people she's really
fun to to watch but in the show they're
changing a bit yes she's still getting
the really big fist which is awesome but
it's not exactly what you would see with
someone like mr fantastic reed richards
who is definitely going to be playing
his own role in the mcu instead now her
power set is even more in the category
of captain marvel of monica rambo but
with its own unique aesthetic it seems
like they come from these bands these
bracelets that she wraps around her
wrists i believe i may be wrong but
these could be the mega bands so mega
bands are some creed technology from the
captain marvel comics that originally
the cree supreme intelligence gifts to
captain marvel marvel that was a trap it
traps marvel in the negative zone so the
negative zone is a big thing
specifically from the fantastic four
comics it's like a pocket dimension
where the fantastic four and doom get
their powers we have not yet seen it
introduced in the mcu because it was up
until like 2018 2019 considered a fox
property alongside all the x-men in the
fantastic four now is the perfect time
to introduce the negative zone because
it could be both the way that kamala
khan gets her powers as well as reed
richards and all of his buddies these
bands really have the power to open
transdimensional rifts that just slip
the wearer right into that pocket
reality now i may be wrong these may not
be nega-bands they may be given a
different name in the show but i think
that technology is the same i think it's
cree technology which already links
kamalakon with captain marvel but also
brings in the negative zone i really
think it's a perfect fusion of those two
comic back stories and fun fact about
those mega bands in the comics one of
them was melted down to form wedding
rings for hulk lane and wiccan but
anyway back to the trailer whatever this
technology is young kamala finds it and
was not supposed to find it and
combining with her own imagination and
her inner hopes and wants from her point
of view manifest physically in a way
that gives her actual physical
superpowers if you think about it this
is also rooted in the supreme
intelligence back from the captain
marvel film in fact we don't even know
what the supreme intelligence really
looks like it's a shape-shifting form
based off of whatever is inside your
mind the same will be true for miss
marvel's power set using that kind of
magical realism conceit to manifest the
hero's power in the mcu i don't believe
has been done before other than what we
saw in wanda vision right which is
really cool it was wanda's grief
manifesting as this kind of sitcom
pocket reality in this case it's going
to be a kid's wish fulfillment coming to
life via cree technology projected from
her fists whether that projection is a
giant fist to wallop someone a shield or
little things that she can walk on now
there's already a lot of implications
that we could draw from this trailer we
know for sure that imanvillani as uh
kamala is gonna come back in the marvels
with brie larson and tiana paris in
february of next year and definitely
this show itself with its tone with its
production design definitely feels like
marvel testing out reaching out to a
younger audience you could totally
imagine this show working as a prelude
to a young avengers title even though
kamala isn't really known to be a member
of the young avengers in the comics
totally she could be one in the mcu yeah
there are some fun easter eggs in this
trailer you see the circle q store from
the comics she's definitely drawing a
doodle of ant-man at the beginning look
i feel like there is a lot in this
trailer that i'm only gonna find when i
go frame by frame so forgive me if i
don't spot something right away i just
think it's so cool how we see her
shifting in and out of whatever that
pocket reality is hopefully the negative
zone because it looks like when she
shifts into that reality she's already
in the middle of some kind of war with
everyone else who is trapped there or
perhaps if it is cree technology it
links her with the mind and body of a
past cree warrior and she's tapping back
into that power set bringing it back up
with her into her present reality and he
used the weekends blinded by the light
it's just perfect for what she's going
through because her powers emanate from
her as a kind of light a light that she
doesn't fully understand yet she's
blinded by it you know when she gets
transported back into another realm that
light overwhelms her but it's light that
she knows that she needs back in her
present day look miss marvel looks
really really fun obviously this is
disney's opportunity to reach out to
completely new audiences but i think
there's going to be a ton of reasons to
love it and the fact that it's coming
june 8th that's a wednesday right in the
middle of the season of obi-wan kenobi
on disney plus which means for the first
time we're going to be getting major
series dropping on the same day in the
month of june on disney plus how will we
keep up with it we will find a way but
i'm just very excited to have all this
great stuff to talk about anyway my
breakdown of this trailer frame by frame
all the easter eggs you missed is coming
tomorrow check out newrockstarsmerch.com
for all of our great merch options i'm
sure we'll have some great kamala khan
designs coming out soon you can follow
me at eavos on instagram and twitter
follow new rockstars thanks for watching
and uh back to sleep just kidding i got
to work
[Music]
you